So we've now drawn
pictures of the interaction
of a person jumping off
a cart in both the ground
frame and a reference frame
moving with velocity, vc, which
is the final speed of the cart.
These were pictures in the
reference frame moving with vc,
and these are the
pictures-- momentum
diagrams-- of the person and
the cart in the ground frame.
Now, we would like to apply
the momentum principle
to solve for vp and vc.
We are given that the velocity
of the person in the moving
frame, u.
We'll treat this as
a given quantity.
And we'll express
the velocity, vc,
and so we want to find vc and
vp in terms of u and p and mc.
Now, we'll use the
ground frame first,
and our assumption here is that
the person jumped horizontally
and that there are
no external forces
in the horizontal direction.
So all of the vectors
we've drawn are horizontal,
and there's no external forces
in the horizontal direction.
Then we know that the initial
momentum of the system
is equal to the final
momentum of the system.
In our initial picture,
nothing is moving.
And in our final
picture, we have
m cart v cart plus m
person v person is 0.
Now, recall that we also showed
that the velocity of the person
in the ground frame is related
to the velocity of the person
in the moving frame by
adding the relative velocity
of the two frames.
The relative velocity
of the two frames
is the velocity of the cart, vc,
so what we have is vc plus u.
So this is how vp
is related to u.
And now, I can use
this start equation
to write it as 0 equals mc
vc plus mp times vc plus u.
And by adding terms, I get that
mc plus mp vc equals minus mpu.
Or the velocity of the cart
is equal to minus mpu divided
by mc plus mp.
Now that I have the
velocity of the cart,
I can just substitute
that in here
to find the velocity of the
person, which, remember,
was the velocity
of the cart plus u.
So now, I've solved this
problem in the ground frame.
Next, I'll do the same
analysis in the moving frame.